do you guys worry that this conversation
is happening with a ferocity that is
going to alienate some people oh yeah I
think tons of men their whole view of
this is that it's an overreaction eggs
and people are being treated unfairly
and that's that's where they start with
this I don't think this is an
overreaction I think it's over
correction and it's it's about time it's
about creating an environment where
women have equal representation
visibility and voice that's the most
important thing you've got to go down to
a very young age and get the young kids
to say this is wrong mm-hmm and change
the culture we need to get rid of that
talk where we look at a girl as not able
to be as good as Forte's as a boy or
saying you throw like a girl or you run
like a girl that's on us or that's on
our generation the big guys are gonna
fall down and the rest of us are gonna
be you know standing or picking up the
pieces to try to figure out really how
we make progress so we're this this is
the beginning of it it's so we're you
know we're seeing we're seeing the the
monuments fall right now